[Music]
let's go out to Tampa Florida and talk
to Emily what's up
Emily hi Dr John I'm doing well awesome
what's happening what's up yeah so my
question is how do I begin to enjoy my
life outside of work
essentially usually that has to do with
um
a life outside of work that you don't
enjoy I mean yeah I don't know I so some
context um I'm a teacher and I work I
mean probably at least 60 hours a week
doing that and then I do some volunteer
work and then I'm getting my um
education master's degree and so I'm
just I'm just kind of always on the go
and then when I get home I'm married and
you know I do have a happy marriage of
course it has its ups and downs but when
I get home I don't intend to feel this
way but I kind of just feel a sense of
just bless like I feel kind of hopeless
and I don't enjoy anything um and it's
not that I am looking to go back to work
but when I'm at work I don't feel that
way
essentially does it have to do with the
fact that when you go to work as a
teacher which is what I've been I've
spent my whole career doing that there's
always going to be outliers right
there's outliers in every job there's
goofballs in every job but on the whole
you go to work with a group of people
who have a shared sense of
purpose we're going to change the lives
of these kids sometimes it's we're going
to provide these kids a safe place to go
sometimes it's we're going to teach
these kids and push them really hard
because we think they're capable of more
than they are but you have a shared
sense of optimism and we're going to
take X and we're going to walk walk
alongside people until it becomes
why and then you go
home and you
don't you don't share that same sense of
I've got a partner in here we're working
on the thing together and we're creating
something amazing and we're Crea like
it's X and we're creating y so you get
home and you just
goah am I right or wrong I could be
wrong you're no you're completely right
that's not something I had ever thought
about uh my husband he doesn't right now
he's actually not working at all but um
why I so he I you know I've been
thinking about it a lot this month at
first I was very frustrated with him
because I felt like he wasn't driven
right he didn't he wasn't interested in
working um but he i' I've realized now I
think he's actually struggling from some
kind of depression um because even
applying for jobs was very difficult for
him and I kind of uh took the lead on
that now that he's gotten offered
interviews he's gotten a little bit more
driven about it um yeah so I think
there's something mentally going on
there um I'm gonna say this and I mean
it with all due respect in my soul and
I'm trying to be kind and loving I don't
care he's got to get a
job yeah the damning nature
of low-level dymia that H this sucks I
got fired or I got laid off or whatever
did he quit or he get fired happened he
did get he did quit he was kind of
miserable in his last job so he did quit
so there's just you sit at home and you
wait for
motivation you wait for the perfect
thing and it doesn't exist you have to
go manufacture it and you manufacture it
by go get a
job yeah and you don't quit a job unless
you have another job I don't care how
miserable it
is you you you you even if it's hey I'm
quitting the six figure job and I got a
job sacking groceries because I got to
do something to
contribute both for my psychology and my
physiology and for like we got to have
money in this
account um but it becomes this this
spiral that's really hard to get out of
I hate this I hate this I hate this the
alternative I mean the the fantasy on
the other side of that is my life will
be so much better if with not this MH
and then you get home and
and then it's well it will only be good
if it will only be good if and I'm not
good and it turns into this just
poison and here's what
happens you lose respect for your
husband
Fair yeah just say it out loud yes and
and I know that's hard to say out loud
because I know you love him I know he's
a great guy I'm not saying he's not a
good guy okay right right but it's hard
to be be optimistic it's hard to build
something it's hard to have hope and
hope is just this idea that tomorrow's
going to be a little bit better than
today or maybe a lot better than
today and it's hard to have hope when
you don't have
respect yeah
right yeah and for a while you know um
you know I get home and I feel like my
husband he's on his phone a lot even
whenever he's off of work and that just
really frustrates me and so I think
you're correct in that don't apologize
for your frustration Emily yeah you
should be frustrated I'm frustrated for
you yeah if he called my show and said
my wife is really frustrated with me and
I don't think it's fair I quit my job CU
I just hated it and now I sit at home
waiting for the right thing I would have
a hard time being compassionate to
him yeah and I would tell him go find a
job today any kind of job at that's
going to be the step forward to getting
some sense in your body that that
um
uh like you start standing on your own
two feet again after being lost at
sea yeah well something I've learned in
the last you know five years of marriage
is I can't make him so what what is your
advice how do I you know how do I help
him um I think there's a couple you're
exactly right and the fact that you
learned this in the first five years
means you are way ahead of most
marriages which is awesome it took me
like 20 years to figure that out um all
right here's a CLE couple things one I
want you to spend some time being very
honest with Emily and right now you have
been spent a lot of time being a mother
to your
husband and when you're a mom to your
husband I'm going to say this I know it
sounds gross I've gotten some Flack in
the past but I don't care it's true no
Mom wants to have sex with their
son no Mom wants to have intimate
relations with their son outside of
sex no um you don't want to come home
and have a third job or a fourth job
after grad school and your service to
your community and your NeverEnding
teaching
job and your fourth job is is caring for
this giant infant
adult and I'll go one step further if he
does have some significant depress
depressive issues those are
real and maybe this isn't the moment for
him to get a job this is the moment that
he gets his butt into
care yeah just sitting at home on your
phone is a
nogo and so I want you to be honest for
the first time in a long
time with I want you to write down in a
notebook I've lost respect for my
husband because I saw him face
adversity and I saw him bow
out because your body feels that you got
to be honest with yourself okay
and I think you have to stop apologizing
for being frustrated and stop
apologizing for feeling burnt out you
know what burnout is it's when your body
says I quit because you're not getting
the message you're trying to carry the
load of two people at your home and
trying to create a home with a guy who
has no interest in creating a
home yeah right that's are hard stuff
and the Second Step here is after you're
honest with yourself and you write some
of these things down and you're probably
going to shock yourself with what you
write
down because it's going to be hard
the next step is not to go bomb him with
these things that's not fair to anybody
okay what is fair is you sitting at the
table and saying the
following here are the boundaries I'm
drawing here's what I'm going to do
moving
forward I am going to go see a counselor
because I have a husband that refuses to
get
work I am going to fill in the blank if
I I come home and you have not applied
for a single job today and you've sat
here on your phone I am going to take
myself out to
dinner see what I'm saying this is not
bombing him with you need to do this you
need to do this because that hasn't
worked it's not gonna work yeah it's you
being very clear about here's what I'm
going to
do I'm going to take care of myself I'm
going to go to the gym I'm going to
continue to work hard I'm going to begin
to eat a little
healthier I'm not going to wallow around
and be mad at you and then be mad at
myself for being mad at you and that
spir you know that spiral I'm talking
about yeah you're like yeah yeah I live
that all the time all right I threw a
lot at you tell me what you're feeling
on the way
back um yeah I think I I'm feeling um I
don't know I feel like I'm I'm a little
worried that it's nothing's going to
change okay but nothing's changing yeah
yeah
yeah um you know and and as you're
mentioning I think these are great steps
just to take care of me because that's
really all I can do I know that um and
hopefully yeah hopefully he'll get the
message but yeah we've had conversations
before where you know I talk with him
and we kind of go over plans that we had
when we first got married and and then
it by the end of it I feel like we're in
agreement and then you know six months
down the road I look back and nothing's
changed well and have you sat down said
I feel like you have not been honest
with
me I feel unloved in this
home what do you mean I love you and I
always want to have sex with you when
I've had four beers what do you mean and
you can say because we made some
agreements and you've chosen to not
uphold your end of those agreements
which leaves me all
alone yeah and those are scary
conversations cuz here's why he might
say well screw you then I'm out mhm but
right now he said screw you I'm
in
Fair yeah know that makes
sense I guess the the the hardest thing
for you is you don't have an easy path
forward yeah you have a I'm going to say
nothing and just continue this thing on
and hope he gets a job and hope it
solves all his problems it will not
within 6 months he's going to tell you
he hates this job and it's killing him
and the boss is an idiot and his
co-workers are morons and he's going to
quit I'm telling you right
now or you can have a really hard hard
series of conversations not about what
he needs to fix but about what you're
gonna
do what do I do in the case that he
because sometimes he'll get really
frustrated and say you know oh all these
things that I do for you I thought you
know you loved me you are you telling me
that X Y and Z doesn't mean anything to
you like he gets he can get kind of
defensive like that what would you
recommend I do that's that's how that's
how children respond right which is like
well then I'm taking my ball and going
home here's what you can say you can say
I hear that you have chosen to try to
love me in ways that you
like that make that you have chosen I'm
telling you what I need to feel loved in
this home in this
marriage
oh so if I just make dinner for you I
never asked you to make dinner that's a
choice you made I did ask you to get a
job I did ask you if you're not working
and you're just sitting here that when
we get home the house is cleaned up and
you're not just sitting there on your
phone play video
games right because that that's just all
that is is a look over here look over
here look over here look over here it's
just a
distraction and here's guys do it a lot
women do it too but guys do it a lot
with oh I'm working all day it was when
my wife told me I'm not asking you to do
that yeah I'm asking you to be here with
me because I had the opposite problem I
was working 24 hours a day
365 was the opposite issue and when I
would come at her with what your husband
does just the opposite oh I do this and
this and this and she's like dude I
never asked for any of that I asked for
you and then I was like oh crap I don't
know I don't know how to do
that and then it was me because I said I
do I had to go figure out that that set
of skills and I had to go learn it and
figure it out similarly on the other
side oh I do this and this and this
that's not what I
asked I asked that we build something
together and you said I do and you said
I'm in and you're
not so here's what I'm going to
do but if somebody throws a little was
little temper tant fromy things oh
you're just ungrateful no no what I'm
talking about it's just distraction
just distraction and you may have to
walk away from the table and say hey I'm
going to come back to this conversation
I'm going to come back in 30 minutes
because right now um you're acting
you're you're you're talking to me as
though I'm seven and I'm not I'm gonna
come back in 30 minutes let's let's
let's
reconvene it's hard I don't envy
you but to your husband if he's
listening you have to get a job you got
to go work and if you can't work I know
those people I've sat with them fine you
got to go get
help you got to go see somebody you got
to go check yourself into an impatient
Clinic you have to do the work just
sitting at home on your phone is not a
solution particularly while you're wife
is working 60 hours a week plus grad
school plus serving the community
enough be somebody worthy of being
respected in your own
home sure quit a a toxic job I've had to
do it you've had to do it fine but don't
quit that job for nothing for a couple
of months with on the couch with a cell
phone
no quit that job and go work at a coffee
shop quit that job and start driving
Uber that night quit that job and go
sling boxes at Walmart on the overnight
shift for $25 an hour
tonight and then apply for jobs when
you're not
sleeping
you can't think your way out of these
things on a couch with a cell phone look
around at our culture we're drowning in
I'm just going to think my way out of
this on a couch with a cell
phone you have to go
do Emily thanks for the call call
anytime I have a feeling this these
conversations get harder before they get
better I want you to be honest with
yourself you only have two hard choices
moving forward hard to let things just
be the same way they are and continually
not respect this Manchild that you're
married to or decide I'm Emily and I'm
worth more than this I'm worth being
loved I'm worth a home and a marriage
that I could fight for that I
love I'm GNA have that hard conversation
either way your path forward is hard I
say take the one that's going to result
in the possibility of healing and
change